[Música]
bitcoin se describe a menudo como el oro
del siglo 21 es una moneda digital que
existe solo en el mundo virtual
[Música]
fue creada en 2009 por un programador
desconocido o un grupo de ellos bajo el
nombre saltos y nakamoto la idea de
eliminar intermediarios como bancos o
compañías de tarjetas de crédito y crear
un sistema de pagos de usuario a usuario
permitiendo a todos pagar al otro
directamente un bitcoin se emite
mediante minería resolviendo algoritmos
complejos o problemas matemáticos y
luego es comprado y vendido en bolsas en
línea un registro de cada transacción de
bitcoins se mantiene en el block change
un libro de contabilidad público que
confirma y muestra cómo se está
utilizando la moneda los usuarios
mantienen sus propios fondos de bitcoin
en una billetera digital no hay una
banca central o supervisión y el valor
es negociado por la gente que lo usa
esto significa que el precio crece con
la demanda pero tiende a bajar cuando
las plataformas sufren brechas de
seguridad
pero al igual que el oro sólido hay un
límite solo 21 millones de bitcoins
pueden extraerse o entrar en circulación